brad keller will be on the mount and
after the royals only got three and four
innings from
friday and saturday started they really
need some innings from brad today here
is jorge polanco
and polanco hooks one down the line
and i guess a fair ball because he's
running to second base
so polanco kind of tomahawk that one
yeah you know most left-hand hitters are
our low ball hitters
carry that bat up in the air but watch
this
you're right he gets on top
see now if you're taught to launch that
ball that's a pop up in the infield
all good hitters keith hernandez one of
the best i've played with could get on
top of that high fastball
and polanco in with a stand-up double
anywhere in the middle you got to waste
a pitch how about a slider
and he throws that slider and gets a
swing and a miss and that's out number
two kenta maeda with the old-fashioned
knee-high baseball pants on and
talked about in the open they're not
numbers that kento would like to look at
he wants to improve on
not many strikeouts high batting average
against too many walks high earned run
average
did a pretty good job there with another
split change to get a swinging strike
three leaving ben and tendy at first
base
nothing nothing inning number two final
game of the series there's a strikeout
fast ball on the outside corner see now
he had jeffers checking it out and
looking blue kc pitch tracks he was
those sliders that keller threw early
locked him up he thought he was another
slider was coming and he stuck the
fastball by him and jeffers you got to
go
if brad can get into the sixth or
seventh that would be huge and a swing
by gordon no contact down he goes
so keller gets two strikeouts in the
inning
three in the first two at the bottom of
the second we go royals nothing
minnesota nothing
bottom two one out and the one two
swinging a miss and down he goes on a
splitter
kenta generating a few more swings and
misses so far today two strikeouts
there you go a base hit
the right field by jarrod dyson so he
continues its success
against the twins right-hander sebastian
rivero
and he tries to drop one to ride that's
a hit
dyson races to third he'll make it
safely and sebastian rivero has his
second major league hit and is first at
kaufman stadium
you know he's looking for something up
from the very beginning and there it was
a little two-seamer that did that it was
belt high and he fought it off dyson
read it all the way
and
he got first and third
to left to base head
and the rise is aboard
pull the ball on the ground in his first
inning at bat this is the rise that i
think of every time i see his name in
the lineup another good at-bat by a
left-hand hitter that's a rod kuru type
hit ryze is going to take off for 30.
he's going to make it no throw
heads up base running as keller just
completely fell asleep
as he never looked back to see where
ryze was the royals had nobody near
second base defensively
3-2 cal to larnick who struck out his
first time no score in the third two
down
up the middle and through
arise
advancing to second on the wild pitch
stealing third scores and it's one to
nothing
and the one-two swing and a miss and
down he goes as he chases slider well
off the outside corner
with his third strikeout and the one-two
pitch swing and a miss and down he goes
on a splitter in the dirt picked up by
jeffers and he throws him out up the
line
[Applause]
and he chases that slider down and away
for brad that is strikeout number four
and another o2 pitch
swung on and miss the slider now bounces
away from rivero he has to hurry and he
gets it down to first base in time that
ball rolled quite a ways
behind home plate but rivero got on it
and got it down to santana to complete
the strikeout
and a 2-2 swung on a miss got him boy
nice location look at that 93 in a
perfect spot cheese at the knees see a
lot of those pitches down have been the
splitter and that one had a little fuzz
on it
yeah nice sequence and a perfect spot
for maeda here in the bottom half of the
fourth inning one nothing minnesota
and swung on a miss chased the slider
way outside
so no adjustment here a second time to
line up by the kansas city hitters
three up three down with another couple
of strikeouts through four
pitch on the way swung out and miss got
him
and another swinging strikeout for kenta
maeda wouldn't chase the previous three
and then that one actually
couldn't tell by the grip that one was
more like a breaking ball not the split
grip kevin morgan the de facto bench
coach
then he buzzes a fast ball at the knees
and strikes him out anyway
pretty impressive afternoon so far for
camden
his first call third strike
one out
here's max kelper to back kept over two
next day but pitch starters
here's a deep drive to right and that's
how you respond to having the tower buzz
yeah
kepler connecting for his seventh home
run of the year and it's two to nothing
moves right back across like thigh high
inner half which a lefty loves see him
just drop the barrel on it it's like
phil mickelson hitting a driver
90th pitch for maeda
split change another swinging strikeout
his ninth strikeout of the game eight of
them on swings see i just throw the
pitch count on out the window here when
you see a guy dealing like this it's
like taking blake snell out in the world
series when you've got stuff going for
you like that i mean get on that horse
and ride it to the finish line if
santana would reach i'm not sure if
he'll get a chance to face salvador
perez
strong on a foul tip hung on by jeffers
and here is strikeout number 10 for
kenta maeda
nice job here this afternoon twins
leading 2-0 he was brilliant today danny
gave up two hits in the second and that
was it no runs a walk and struck out a
season i-10
here is polanco hitting right-handed
against lovelady
a high fly to deep left field ben and
tendy going back and polanco goes deep
with a man aboard his tenth of the year
and the twins have doubled the lead
just missed a home run in his last at
bat left-handed but he got one hitting
right-handed
there's a cement mixer you see no dot on
that one yeah rub up a new one
and polanco right on time and now alex
carroll off over three
coils
with just two hits deep center field
looking up and that one is gone
carol off seventh
his fifth against kansas city pitching
yeah there's another one of those flat
sliders right over the middle of the
plate
and boy what a show these left-hand
twins hitters have put on between
larnick and arise and now kirilla from
kepler
seventh home run is third against a
left-handed pitcher and his fifth
against kansas city isn't it amazing how
good a team looks when they get a solid
outing from their starters they look
like a completely different team rises
had a good day at the plate and in the
field made a nice play on a bud early in
the ball game but he's reached three
times and scored twice
drive to right center field he's got
three hits
one to each field that one going to
right and this one for extra bases with
runners in scoring position can add to
that now rise at third infield in a
swinging line drive
to right a base hit so larnick pulls a
sharp line drive runs scoring single to
right field the rise is in
six nothing twins now ryan o'hearn for
him to get some reps
and now he knocks one sharply to left
field and that's going to be a fair ball
off the wall
and o'hearn
slides in safely with a two-out double
dyson singled his first time up
there's a base hit through the whole
left side oh hearn to score dozier to
score it's a 6-2 ball game and the
royals keep competing on offense
one ball two strikes on jorge soleil
and the one-two swag gonna miss he
struck him out in the high fastball and
that's the game the twins win six to two
[Music]
now the twins salvage one in this series
and salvage one on this disappointing
road trip they finish one and five
and now we're coming home for a
week-long home stand before the all-star
break white sox for three tigers for
four
and that begins tomorrow night at 6 10
against chicago in the final twin six
royals two will